welcome to the man of recaps this is the
umbrella academy season two remember at
the end of season one the umbrella
academy had just failed to stop their
sibling bonya from accidentally
destroying the moon and causing the
apocalypse there was no way to stop it
so their brother number five used his
time travel powers to get them out of
there but he can't really control his
time traveling so he ends up by himself
in the 60s where a soviet invasion is
underway and in this timeline his
siblings are all here fighting it with
their full powers unlocked the umbrella
academy in superhero mode but in the end
they still fail and it's apocalypse time
again but five is picked up by our old
friend hazel who warped him to safety
one week earlier remember he quit his
job as an assassin for the time
commission and lived happily ever after
with his love the donut lady he's come
out of retirement to help five stop this
apocalypse but the time commission sent
new assassins these three blonde
brothers the swedes tragically they kill
hazel and damage the briefcase so five
is stuck here on his own five notices
someone's been monitoring this alleyway
so he pays him a visit and it's a crazy
conspiracy theorist who has seen all of
his siblings land here one year apart
yes in the time jump they all got split
up first to land is the hilarious klaus
along with of course his ghost brother
ben klaus had a great time living in the
60s in fact he started a new wave cult
which was fun for a while until it got
old alison landed next but she has not
had a great time remember time travel's
no fun if you're not white but she's
found happiness here met a wonderful man
and got married now they're working as
civil rights leaders next was number one
the big man luther who without his
siblings around became a boxer working
for a gangster banya herself landed with
amnesia has no memory of who she is she
ended up working as a live-in nanny and
is the third wheel in this unhappy
marriage but has become real close with
the wife last was diego who was a bit of
a hero complex and realized his destiny
was to save jfk but running around
yelling about the president's
assassination landed him in a mental
hospital so five tries to recruit his
wayward siblings into stopping the
apocalypse again but this time they're
not interested they're all more
concerned with their new lives here
diego though is interested he's like
great bust me out here we'll save jfk
but he's like you idiot saving jfk is
probably what starts the apocalypse i'd
better leave you here for now but
diego's got a pseudo girlfriend in here
lila who's real resourceful and breaks
him out five's like fine you guys can
join but forget about the jfk stuff five
has a lead the video that hazel dropped
him before he died and turns out it's
all about the jfk assassination told ya
but who's that on the grassy knoll it's
someone unexpected their adopted father
sir reginald hargreaves they go to his
umbrella factory which is of course a
cover for his secret experiments
including the super cute baby pogo butts
original hargreaves in the prime of his
life doesn't appreciate intruders and
easily fights them off they track him
down to a fancy party where they meet
his girlfriend their robot mom or the
living woman she was based on they
discover their dad is part of a secret
society that is indeed planning to kill
the president but now they're
interrupted when the swedes bust in and
oh get diego he and laila have fallen in
love but she doesn't save him she goes
to save five instead because those were
her orders she's working undercover for
the handler years ago on a mission she
found lyla as a kid and racer as her own
to be a time travel assassin remember
she was shot at the end of season one
but it just grazed her she's okay but
she gets some bad news from her boss aj
who is inexplicably a goldfish she's
been demoted and she's not happy about
that and now she's got her own master
plan to get back on top of the
commission meanwhile the other siblings
are doing their own thing allison's
organizing a protest which doesn't go
well she has to use her powers to save
her husband vanya uses her powers to
save the kid from drowning when she
gives him cpr he gets some of her power
so watch out for that and soon she and
[ __ ] admit their feelings for each
other oh they're in love house goes to
visit the younger version of his vietnam
boyfriend yeah remember he was trapped
there for a year last season and they
fell in love but he died hey kid i'm
your time traveling boyfriend from the
future you need to not enlist which
obviously doesn't go well and klaus
starts drinking again on a depression
bender but finally the siblings start
reuniting most notably luther and
allison who have had a crush on each
other since they were teenagers it is
weird because their adopted siblings but
the umbrella academy was more of a
school than a family but he hasn't yet
told her how he feels and when he finds
out she's married he goes on a
depression bender of his own but now
finally they all get together umbrella
academy reunited five tries to keep him
on track but per usual the family
reunion turns into an awesome sibling
dance party but then it's time to meet
their father who's like alright you
bunch of weirdos what's going on they
explain they're his adopted superhero
kids from the future who need to stop
him from killing jfk and causing the
apocalypse but he doesn't want to hear
it he's a real tough love kind of dad
bordering on no love kinda dad so pretty
soon all their daddy issues come out and
the conversations derailed so it's up to
five to keep the plot on track when he
goes to visit lila and the handler she's
willing to stop the apocalypse and get
his family back home if he assassinates
the board of directors for her and
remember five as a master assassin one
of the best the time commission ever had
and so five helps her smack this fish
but she kind of betrays him she gives
him the briefcase but it's only active
for one hour so his five rushes to
wrangle his wayward siblings it's the
now famous meme where he and bonya pass
each other driving we have a ride home
we gotta go but bonnie doesn't want to
leave she's gonna run off with [ __ ] and
start a new life unfortunately her
husband found out and they're picked up
by the cops and bonnie's got to use her
powers which naturally lands her in fbi
custody class meanwhile is having an
argument with his ghost brother ben
who's sick of being in the background
all the time so class agrees to try
something new and let ben possess him
for a while and it's a real cute scene
as ben enjoys having a body allison is
saying goodbye to her wonderful husband
when they get a visit from the swedes
yeah there was a whole thing where the
handler was giving them fake missions
that got one of them killed and blamed
it on the umbrella academy so to save
her husband allison's got to use her
powers again i heard a rumor you killed
your brother oh that's rough but now the
handler is in charge with her adopted
daughter lila as a right-hand woman she
apologizes to diego but drugs him and
kidnaps him and recruits him to be in
the time commission so as the timer's
ticking down klaus and ben are the only
ones that make it so they've missed
their ride still stuck in the past so
five has one last desperate idea because
you know who just came to town his older
self on assignment here to kill kennedy
before he quit the commission and went
back in time in the first place and so
five meets his older self although
remember the young one is technically
older but being in the room with another
version of you comes with a range of
side effects and so they devolve into
sweaty itchy farty paranoia diego
meanwhile's being put through
orientation but he immediately sneaks
off and meets the mild-mannered herb
who's leading the resistance against the
handler he helps diego find out what
causes this apocalypse and turns out
it's vanya again when she explodes they
assume it's the russians and world war
iii so diego busting to recruit some
siblings because it's happening right
now the fbi is torturing her which is
making her lose control she's too strong
none of them can reach her except ghost
ben who can walk right through and
possesses her inside her mind she
remembers everything and feels bad about
causing the apocalypse twice but he's
like yo you're a good person you can
control this but unfortunately being
here is ripping him apart and ghost ben
dies but with his sacrifice the day is
saved and with the apocalypse averted
diego thinks he can still save jfk hold
five meanwhile getting ready to
assassinate him when the fives finally
turn on each other and luther stuck in a
teleporter fight in the end he sides
with young five though it's like quick
open the portal preserve the time loop
but as they kick old five through the
briefcase is destroyed again but now
it's time to find out who actually does
kill jfk diego thinks it's their father
and he's running in and tackles him oh
but it's a decoy and the shots ring out
john f kennedy killed as we know it you
just can't change history it was the
secret society that killed him but turns
out their father had no part of it now
remember in a very brief scene in season
one we found out that's original
hargreaves is an alien and now he's
revealing himself takes off his human
mask and kills this whole group and so
history is mostly preserved although the
umbrella academy are now america's most
wanted but now something's happening at
banya's farm she can tell the kids in
danger they were trying to leave but her
husband didn't let her and guns are
dangerous oh it went off but because of
her powers the bull bounced back and
killed his dad and now he's like
overloading maybe starting another
apocalypse banya's like yo fam i need
your help and at first they shut her
down again but then it's a heartful
scene when they all pile in the car like
hey you're our sibling and we're with
you they get to the farm but the
handler's here too and she's brought the
whole army of time travel assassins for
an epic final battle scene diego learns
that he can control not just knives but
bullets too things still look bleak
until vania joins the fray in full
control of her power and boom takes them
all out in one hit except what's this
the handler survived because lila has
vanya powers too and not just vanya
powers she does the thing where she can
take the powers of whoever she's next to
yeah remember the umbrella academy only
included seven of the super babies but
there are a bunch more out there sir
reginald hargreaves didn't get it seems
lila was one of them and that's why the
handler killed her parents and recruited
her now the handler just told her it was
five who killed her parents but five's
like yo it was the handler who gave that
order she's playing yeah the siblings
come together hey you're one of us she
and diego have their big moment i
forgive you i love you baby but this
touching moment is rudely interrupted by
the handler busting in and killing all
of them she doesn't win though because
the final swede finally realizes she was
playing and kills her so that's it i
guess the show's over but five tries
something he's never tried before when
making big time jumps he can't really
control it but he figures let me just go
back a few seconds just in time to save
his family then the swede busts in and
kills the handler lyla's confused though
so she grabs a briefcase and warps out
on her own so the time commission's
under new management they're happy to
stop the apocalypse and let the umbrella
academy back home bonnie's like yo girl
come with me but time travels a bit much
she's gonna go off for a simple life
with her son who by the way still has
some powers so the umbrella academy is
headed back to the future and with a
functioning briefcase it's nice and easy
they're back home the day after the
original apocalypse which didn't happen
this time so the day is saved but this
timeline is different because their
father is still alive he was
disappointed with his weird
dysfunctional super team so he did
things differently this time he created
not the umbrella academy but the sparrow
academy and it's led by a mean emo
haircut version of ben and that's where
the umbrella academy season 2 comes to
an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]